[Music]
oh my goodness i did it you guys you did
it we have a boy you guys it's a boy and
we officially decided on his name and it
is luca
so we have a baby boy named luca
right now the baby is going to be
dressed for the first time in his own
clothes oh my gosh i'm so excited it is
time to finally put on his clothes and i
shopped more i got this intentionally
for his going home outfit we get to take
baby home he gets to meet brother i'm so
excited isaac just got out of school too
so he's gonna be home by the time we get
there oh man i haven't put on a once in
a baby in
so long let's see how we do
this is
this is quite difficult not as easy as i
remember i would say it's a lost skill
of yours now
i'll get it back okay it's just taking
me a little while now you're going to
learn it's going to be a new school year
true yeah like i've already tried
putting on a few like uh shirts and
stuff that the hospital supplied onto
luca and getting the arms through the
sleeves is one of the hardest things in
the world looking super handsome there
luca hello
see says hello
yeah you're gonna need some pre-made
clothes
look how big it all looks on him my baby
even that pacifier is like huge on his
face tiny little face
[Music]
you're all set my baby ah you're so cute
oh my goodness look at this it's so
small
i love to measure my children by my
forearm length
because that's how i measured isaac i
could not lean over like this when i had
isaac the c-section oh yeah no way
look at this
[Music]
you're cute
both you guys are so cute
next up
home welcome to your car luca
yeah we got this for you dude it's the
baby mobile you're all your baby stuff
back here
all right my baby
welcome to your car
you're so small
how do you fit when doing the car seat
test uh they made it really tight how
like would blankets or something no they
just made it really really tight on them
oh like the strap
yeah yeah i'm gonna do that i'm just
like looking at how it all fits already
did they leave these on
yes it looks like the car seat's gonna
eat them i'm so small in them
[Music]
he looks good he looks safe nice and
safe we also bought one of these guys
right here these mirrors so you can see
the baby and the reflection
while i drive it's gonna be your first
time seeing him in the reflection i know
i've been looking forward to that since
we installed it yeah i have
already all aboard can you see baby
can you access luca yep all righty bye
[Applause]
hi family you see him
oh
the camera's in the way
hold on let me see if i can do it
do you need to reposition the mirror
i see him
i see him hi luca luca it's your dad
speaking
luke ah i am your father
this is his first car ride oh my gosh
from the side profile you can really see
how he has this hairy peach fuzz
he has like a drop shadow on this side
say a drop shadow photoshop yeah
yeah
because i know you're gonna know what
that that is
welcome home luca we're home
oh
look your brother oh my gosh he's here
no
cuties
isaac meet your little brother
oh my god
[Music]
hi luca how's it going
uh
he's so precious
you know huh he's so small he's so tiny
my cuties i can't believe my my two sons
come here baby hey baby i haven't seen
you since
sunday yeah since i was since this
little guy was inside
i know it's now wednesday we get to come
home
you're a big brother now dude
[Music]
he's really hairy his shoulders are
really hairy too it's so cute
[Music]
he looks like a little monkey what are
you thinking
so crazy
my little brother yeah
known for the next
rest of my life yeah
i know
baby i can't believe it you have a you
have a sibling now
hi luca
no he's tagged
he's so small
show him to the house yeah let's bring
them in
you're skinny again
yeah she lost a lot of weight
oh my boobies are really hard though
i
lost weight here and gained it up here i
don't know why but i was just
like from sunday to now i feel like i've
just been nervous and like a lot of
stuff going on and it's finally all over
i can relax oh these are the ones where
you can stick your finger through and
those are supposed to they're supposed
to
yeah be nipples me mom i'm just like you
okay
[Music]
ready
big brother's leading the tour look
look at this
we have we have zoe here oh yeah the
cats
i don't know what that's gonna be like
we got a new family member
this is luca
hey stop smelling his butt i'm trying to
show you luca look
like that doesn't smell like food
they're just so like whatever look
look there's a baby right here there's a
baby he's looking at your hand he's like
where's the food in your hand though
maya
smell who's our new family member their
smell
cuties so we totally skipped trash day
yeah it smells we should have taken
trash out i don't know oh
[Music]
whenever you're
ready nice
[Music]
he looks tiny in there
he can't even see over the thing
[Laughter]
yeah
that newborn life it's hard coming into
the world that's how you were too
can you see your face in him because i
could totally see
a lot right isaac feels ready now to
hold his little brother
get ready
here you go
little brother
[Music]
oh my gosh let me take a picture you're
like holding your mini me you're holding
on perfectly baby yeah it's really good
perfect i'm flexing my muscles so it's
like a pillow yeah you're doing so good
[Music]
well this is our first family hug can i
jump in first
family hug
[Music]
baby boys
you're crying
stop it i'm trying so hard not to pray
through your eyes this is your little
brother baby
a little bro
my eyes are sweating
me and luke were just like
you guys are too emotional
two bros just chilling
what's he look like with that beanie can
you take it off
he looks so cute
so his head had to be shaped to like
make his way out
so it's a little like
a little comb but it's gonna
go i'll get round again yeah but look he
does have big ears
look at this one he's gonna have such
big ears people are going to call you
monkey
he totally has your whole face though
like those eyes this is isaac right here
all right it's time to show luca
upstairs of his home he's gonna be our
new roommate yeah until you give up your
office until i get to my office and then
he's gonna be isaac's
roommate yeah this buddy an expert
expert these are the smells sounds and
sights of your home
yeah how do we leave this the last time
i was in here i was in labor oh yeah
that looked pretty good for for a family
that was
trying to do a photo shoot yeah we did a
photo shoot it's okay
we did a photo shoot take a shower got
ready for your welcome our makeshift
baby
the real baby yeah i feel like we're
gonna use this bear to track
his growth
what bra that nana gave you look at that
you're so much smaller than your bear
this is gonna be your bassinet oh yeah
we can use that bouncer now
what is this
oh that's a sledgehammer
that's to put on the wall for the mobile
papa
[Music]
are you ready to eat almost you're going
a really long time without eating
cutie look at that yawn
[Music]
all right
this is your best net in the meantime
your crib gets here not gonna get here
until the first week of march oh yeah
you don't cover his face hi luca you're
in your bed now dude this is your
bassinet it rocks too long oh this is
tight
i've been manual i've been like holding
his chest and going like this
like rocco no i can just do this yeah
nice uncle michael got it for you it's
best in it
cutie yeah he's hungry okay time to eat
like all three of my boys are going to
be eating oh yeah
doordash is coming
[Music]
look at his eyes
he's opened his eyes we haven't seen his
eyes in like forever since we
since he's been in the whole uh jaundice
blue light club yeah i know
hi baby
you're finally awake literally right
when we want to go to sleep that's
amazing
the whole time we've been home he's been
sleeping incredible
you're so funny
look at that stretch those two stretch
i dreamed of i've dreamt of this moment
for like
so long
but ever since that picture was taken
like the next day i was like okay start
dreaming about baby and what day would
be life with baby would be like
yeah now we're here yeah we're here
it's been a long journey oh yeah five
years five years for you to come luca
i look like he's trying to grab his
bottle um
he did that he's camera shy
all right well good night
okay sleepy look
his eyes
you did that a lot when you were a baby
there's one eye the one eye yeah the
same eye too good night luca
oh my god you're so cute
[Music]
you